hours after the attack President Trump
tweeted quote I have just ordered
homeland security to step up already
extreme betting program being
politically correct is fine but not for
this CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell was acting
and deputy director of the CIA he's with
us now good morning good morning
Charlene from what we know this morning
what stands out for you Charlie what
stands out for me is that there is no
doubt in my mind that this was Isis
inspired and the reason is it follows
the ISIS PlayBook perfectly several
months ago Isis published in an
extremist magazine the following get get
a truck kill as many pedestrians as you
possibly can when you can't kill any
more pedestrians get out and either with
a knife or gun kill more and then let
people know either through a note or
through the words you say that you're
doing this on behalf of Isis so he did
all of those things he didn't have a
real gun he out of fake gun but boy did
he follow that playbook it sounds very
textbook but I thought we were gaining
ground with Isis we just did a story
recently celebrating the takeover the
downfall of Isis and Raqqa does that
mean that it really isn't over for them
they're growing stronger so they're not
growing stronger not but nobody should
think that just because we're taking
away their territory in Iraq and Syria
that they're going away right they are
now becoming a normal terrorist
organization they're going underground
they're going into the shadows they will
still have influence they'll still be
able to get their message out should we
expect more people to try to copycat
what happened here in New York as they
have done in Europe so Charlie I think
that's a really important point the
pattern we're seeing in Europe now is an
attack followed by copycat attacks so we
had the the Westminster attack in March
followed by three attacks over the next
four weeks we have the man the
Manchester attack in May followed by
three attacks over the next four weeks
I'm not saying that's going to happen
here but we need to be vigilant about
that and we know the suspect is from
Uzbekistan a former Soviet republic the
caucus is in general like Dagestan where
the tsarnaev brothers were from is a
hotbed for terror recruitment Russia has
traditionally helped us in
counterintelligence in the past given
the heightened tensions between the US
and Russia now
that been affected at all are they still
cooperating with us on intelligence so
the relationship between Russian
intelligence and US intelligence has
never been great even on
counterterrorism it is they are very
difficult to work with the question that
hangs over this is what can police and
homeland security people do to prevent
this kind of attack Charlie it's very
very difficult if if the individual
doesn't doesn't tell other people what
they're planning or doesn't express
their extremist views to other people
and those other people come forward to
the to authorities you're not going to
find the person and you can't put
barriers up everywhere where there are
pedestrians this is virtually impossible
to stop which is why the terrorists are
so attracted to and the individual the
individuals don't mind dying people say
listen you got to live your life more
people die in car accidents more people
die and fall in the shower what do you
say to that like what I say to that is
your car and your your bathtub aren't
trying to kill you right and those kind
of attacks don't lead people to want to
give up their civil rights but terrorist
attacks do fundamentally different I
think what my Camaro always good to have
you here